for brother zimmerman trying to uh get
his fourth win era
it's down under five runs a game
for the first time in a while
one two pitch
another one popped up this one looks
like it's in play
ryan castle there for the first out
so two out and now alonso
that's drilled in the air to left field
deep back toward the wall and it's out
of here pete alonzo with a line drive
two-run homer his eighth home run of the
season and the mitch jump in front early
two-nothing
alonso got a 2-0 pitch and he cranks it
see the toyota numbers for david
peterson it's been 50 50. some up some
down
and mullens hits the slider on the
ground into the chef lindor with the
running toss to get mullins one away
bounced up the middle could be two
there's one
on to first safe safe at first so again
mod castle running hard down the line
beats it by half a step he just has good
speed
there it is and
gets it to him and then meanwhile
too close plays and they're going to
look at him
safe there you go
again the 2-2
and he got the fastball in on him and vr
makes the play to first and that retires
the side so peterson gets out of the
inning with three ground balls and a
two-nothing lead
unquantifiable
something about them
bronco bare hands fires got him
now they'll probably look at that
michael franco charging bare hands it
across
for what looks like out number one yeah
not an easy play because you're playing
so deep but
on the run bare hand
yep i think he got it
pat valencia off bereavement and he's
got a fair ball down into the left field
corner
one run in here comes franco he'll score
pat felika welcome back
to rbi
good night for the bartenders couple of
doubles right here there's that
curveball he hangs it and pat doesn't
miss it screamer that just stays fair
malayka takes his lead at second that's
hit well gap right center field they're
not gonna get this one
on the warning track valkyr around third
he scores mullins in at second with an
rbi double as the orioles take a 3-2
lead
go 3-1 we saw what happened when alonso
hit the home run
for bruce zimmerman this is a 3-1
fastball and he just
kind of golfs it into the the hole 11
multi-hit games for freddie on the year
that's hit well
base hit into left center field galvez
around first
and he'll go into second standing up
with a double the fourth
of the night
105.3 miles per hour there's the change
so that two for 22 on at bats ending in
chain jumps that number goes up
hit hard down to third off the glove of
vr no play to be made now calvis in the
third and pedro severinos two for two
ouch
hit well left field
back back and over the head of dominic
smith
one run in the score
severino into third
and valencia's got a double that got on
dominic smith pretty quick did the gym
well it did and you know last year he
de-aged and played a lot of firsts they
said he's playing better
but again this is a tough if you don't
immediately get back because this ball
is ripped
well peterson straight for eight hits
and four runs over two and two thirds
and he's going to exit this game robert
gazellman will come in behind him for
his second straight start
2-2 coming
line toward the center field that's a
diving grab by pilar and that ends the
inning hilar saves a couple of runs with
a diving catch in center field and gets
the mets through the inning
and there's another base hit
oh it's gonna be a double that's yeah
he'll get two
no problem in standing up
back to back doubles for cedric mullins
the hitting machine
well that's now six doubles for the
order not over the weekend tonight
right it's not a bad pitch it's just the
approach
orioles up by two trying to add a run
there he goes right side base hit
mullins will score on that rbi for
mancini
well there you go the professional
hitting right well the team that shifts
the most other than the dodgers
and like they said sometimes it doesn't
go your way here's franco two on nobody
down
that's hit well
deep down the left field line and it is
a fair ball
out of here
michael franco wasn't sure was gonna
stay fair but it is
a
high-towering three-run shot
and the orioles have opened up some
breathing room now
as they've tacked on three more to go up
eight to two
well that's kind of what we expected
when you looked at his resume coming
from the phillies
only missed 10 games multiple fractures
in his face and there's a base hit from
santander in the gap in right center
that's extra bases
anthony with a bad ankle just kind of
glides into second with a stand-up
double
[Applause]
center field that'll fall in santander
gets the green light around third he
comes and he'll go in standing
the orioles had another run
and now they lead it nine to two an rbi
for ryan montcastle santander mont
castle and galvez for the orioles in the
eighth inning the interstate up to 208
that's hit well right center field way
back it is out of here anthony santander
been waiting everything else has been
there just waiting for the long ball and
there it is he doubled his last at baton
in the seats on this one
travis uh lakin senior will come in
pitch the ninth inning
trying to get straightened out stuff's
good
come in you can see the 12 walks 18
innings a bullet into the seats and left
his eighth of the year
and he hits this one out to left that's
deep down the line and that ball is out
of here alonzo's second home run of the
night
his ninth home run of the year
so on the night where nothing else has
gone right for the match alonso's and a
pair of bombs
here we go beginning and
bruce zimmerman settled down meanwhile
the orioles came back
put 10 on the board
and down he goes that'll do it
orioles with another win they're fifth
in the last six games it took care of
business tonight 10-3 the final score
high fives for everybody